Good afternoon, everybody. Welcome to our session.
This is Contextual Challenges in
Blood-Based Early Cancer Detection Tests, and it is put
together by a group called BloodPAC.
BloodPAC is a fantastic group of
industry, academic, government
stakeholders coming together to talk about the
evaluation and implementation of novel blood-based cancer tests,
both for early detection and for MRD.
So if you don't know anything about BloodPAC, please go to our website and check it
out. I am Tina Clark Durr. I'm the VP of epidemiology at
Grail, and I want to bring up my co-chair of the early detection working
group at BloodPAC, Bree Mitchell.
So we are just going to give a little bit of background to the session
today and what our panelists will be addressing, which again, is contextual
challenges in interpreting performance statistics for blood-based
early cancer detection tests.
This is our disclosures. Bree works at Natera. I work at Grail.
So our working group has had a really interesting ride over the last three or
four years, coming together as a first group
of stakeholders interested in setting standards for
evaluating early detection tests.
The first thing we did
when we got together and started talking about this topic is realize that we
were all over the map. We had
unclear direction, and we also were using totally different
words to explain the same concepts to each
other. And we needed to get aligned, and we needed to get
a lexicon. So we first published a lexicon for early cancer
detection so that at least we're speaking the same language.
As part of that work, we realized that there's a very particular word used
regularly in cancer screening about your risk.
Are you high risk for colorectal cancer? Are you average risk?
And that
word is causing all sorts of
confusion in a world where there are multi-cancer tests
and single cancer tests. So we had a great panel discussion here in San
Diego in 2024 to talk about the
notion and the terminology and the ways we're going to think
about risk in the context of cancer screening,
and that was fantastic.
Last year in
Chicago, we also had a really fantastic session to talk
about some of the particular challenges in evaluating the performance
of early cancer detection tests relevant to the gold
standard. What is the gold standard
for
calculating the sensitivity of an early detection test?
For colorectal cancer, we have colonoscopy, and that's worked really nicely as a
gold standard. But for pretty much every other cancer type, we really don't
know if someone truly has or does not have
cancer. So what does that mean for how we calculate these statistics and talk
about these performance measures? And it was a really rich discussion.
Our group has since really evolved into
additional frameworks for how we're talking about clinical validity, and that'll be
the focus
that we dig into today.
Oops, sorry.
So just also some additional context.
Over this journey of the last few years, we're really seeing the
landscape here for blood-based cancer tests
changing rapidly. Just since we got this group together a year
ago, we've seen the first FDA-approved single
cancer early detection test, which is Guardant Shield for
colorectal cancer. That's the first blood test for colorectal
cancer approved.
We have also had the first MCED test submitted to the
PMA, and it's currently under review at the FDA.
There has also been legislation passed by Congress for Medicare coverage
of MCED with FDA approval. So big
kind of movements in the regulatory and reimbursement space.
There's also just been a lot of public discourse
and chatter about blood-based cancer screening with
the introduction of a blood-based option for colorectal cancer
screening. There's been incredible adoption of that test.
I don't know who watches basketball like I do, but I can't watch a game without
seeing either a Cancer Guard ad or now
I'm seeing
Guardant Shield ads too. So there's a lot of
these things appearing in print and
television advertisements. There's pretty
hot media coverage of advances and controversies in the field,
and we've seen some websites put together in order
to allow patients and providers to
compare different tests as consumers, and they're comparing
raw performance statistics both for MRD products as
well as single cancer and multi-cancer blood-based
tests. We've also had just
scratching the surface on the clinical utility data for these
tests. My company, Grail, is
about to present
data at ASCO,
and we did some PR about that a few months ago.
So you may have seen all that, but that's all just to say that these things are
really heating up in the landscape.
So back to this issue that we're now facing. There's so many new products.
There's people developing new products.Comparison of different
technologies and tests is inevitable.
People want to be able to look at these things side by side.
But what we're really here to talk about today is that without
contextualization, without all the information you need in order to
accurately compare these tests, that is just going to lead to widespread
confusion. So on this slide, we have some
examples of things that we've seen in analyst reports from
Wall Street on a website that allows people to line
up
cancer,
both MRD and
early detection tests side by side.
And you can see on the lower left that there's all sorts of
tests with different
study designs and different
statistics and different specificities all just lined up side by
side. The one on the lower right is funny because it's kind of
rank ordering two different statistics entirely, which is
sensitivity for certain cancer types and the PPV.
So you can imagine that if you are not a totally
sophisticated consumer of this information, you're going to get really confused
really fast. So how do we avoid this?
There's definitely a lot of activity in the academic space
to lay out kind of what
the rules of the road should be. This is a paper that was just recently
published last month by Peter Sassini, who presented at our session
last year and is a great thinker in this space.
He's talking about MCED tests here as part of a
reaction to the recent
alliance reference set project of the National Cancer Institute to
compare
MCED technologies using common reference samples.
And he's saying, I've just highlighted some of his most important thoughts here,
that comparison between assays should be based not
cancer type by type for an MCED, but to the union of cancer types that
are targeted from the test. The language we use in our working group to talk
about that concept is the target condition.
Is the target condition one cancer type?
Is it selected cancer types, or is it more of a
pan-cancer set of targets? And that
obviously really matters for MCED, and you need to know
what the target condition is.
He's also saying it's not
possible to line up sensitivity and specificity separately,
because if you have two tests with different specificities, the sensitivity is not
directly comparable, but we see that happen all the time.
Lastly, he's saying, and this does sound like a pretty
big thing to swallow, but if we're going to do this
correctly, we need to
present for the study population.
We need four
levels of stage, detailed cancer type distributions, and for the
cancer-free individuals, we got to look at sex and five-year age group, along
with the correction factor for racial ethnic groups.
So this is kind of just getting at what is it going to take to really
be apples to apples with these things.
And I'm going to let Bree tell you a little bit about what our working group is
proposing to address this.
Yeah. Thanks, Tina. So our working group is really trying to
provide frameworks and common language so that as we see
these tests move into the field, there are ways for stakeholders
across industry, academia, patients, clinicians
to really understand what it is that they're being served
up and how they can interpret it. So we've come up with this framework,
which is at the end of the day, sort of how you fill out your
two-by-two table, which you have to do if you're doing a clinical validation study.
But what are the things that we also have to understand about the data that went
into that two-by-two table in order to really have the right context for
interpreting it?
And these are listed in a numerical order, but really they're
all interrelated.
So you have to define what your intended use population
is. You have to say, who is this test intended for?
This is where, for example, our discussions about risk are important.
Is it high risk or average risk? Does average risk have a meaning?
You have to be able to define a study design.
Is it a case control versus an interventional study, for example?
Those are very different things.
Tina just mentioned the target condition of the test is something that is
more nuanced than it might be obvious at the onset.
So that's whether it's a single cancer, many cancers, all cancers.
You really have to understand that in order to interpret this two-by-two table.
You have to define what the clinical ground truth is.
How do you know that the people in a clinical validation study had or did not have
cancer? And we had, as Tina said, a session about that at AACR
last year,
where we decided that that's really informed both by the study design and
the screening interval of the test and is defined by the screening interval of the
test.
And then you have to really understand and scope what your primary and secondary
endpoints are because that is what drives what becomes...
All of this is what drives what becomes your true positive and false positive
or false negative and true negative kind of quadrants in this
table,
which is then
added complexity for
many of these tests.
The complexity is increased by talking about either a
subset of the target condition or your tissue of origin or cancer signal of
origin.
So there's a lot of components to this, and I think we're very grateful for
AACR for giving us a platform to talk about this.
This is really the third of the sessions we've had around this at
AACR, where we're trying to flush this out as a community, and we want
this community to also weigh in on these questions.
Our intent is to publish a paper on this.
We have published every year sort of components of this, and we
continue to do that. And really that our
understanding of this and our ability to
convey this is largely due to the conversations we get to have
as part of this AACR session.
So-The added nuance
that we've come up with this year for
adding more depth to this conversation is that we
realized we really need a checklist
that helps people walk through what they need to consider
as they're looking at clinical validation.
And so this is the checklist which we will again, intend to publish.
It's based on the STAR checklist, which
is
meant for diagnostics. There's not really something for screening, and so we're
trying to create that as a consortium community.
So in this session, we are really grateful to have a fantastic
lineup of speakers and panelists who will delve into some of these
topics in more detail. So Bob Smith from ACS will
kick us off talking about the statistics that
come out of your two-by-two table and what do we need to think about as we're
developing new blood tests, and what context is going to be important for people to
understand those statistics.
Nima Visvade from OHSU will talk about
the target conditions of the test and how
important it is from a
clinical perspective to really understand that as well as the CSO.
And Asma Shukat will talk about how we think about
translating clinical trial data into intended use populations.
Our trials are very often biased on purpose because we need to get a certain
number of cases of cancer. But then how do you think about that when you're looking
at a test that goes into a population that has a different makeup than what the
trial population was? And then we're very grateful for Anand
Pathak from the FDA to come, and he will give us some thoughts on
these topics. And then Gary Puckrein will be on our
panel as well. So what we'll do is the speakers will come up in order.
They will give their presentations.
Anand will respond, and then we will have a Q&A session, which
Tina and I will moderate. So please think of your questions.
We would love to hear them at the end. So we'll hold those to the end.
And with that, I will invite Bob up to kick us off.
Thanks.
I think that was a perfect introduction to this session.
I also want to thank the organizers for the opportunity to join this
panel for the second year.
Good. I have no financial relationships to disclose.
The core of what this presentation is going to focus on is that we've been doing
single cancer early detection tests for easily
over 50 years, actually much longer than that.
And as we look at these new multi-cancer early detection tests, we have a tendency
to view them through the lens of the measurements and the
evaluations of single cancer early detection tests.
They have some things in common. They clearly
place a high priority on early detection.
We want to know how accurate the tests are.
But the tests are fundamentally different in ways that
make us need to think carefully about how we apply those concepts
in a different way.
Basically, the aim of cancer screening is to detect cancers
or pre-cancers early in their natural history.
If we do that, we can sometimes prevent the disease, or we can
find it early enough to alter the natural history, and
the patient can have a much better outcome.
It's important to understand, though, at the core, a screening test is
not a diagnostic test. It is not intended to diagnose
cancer. It basically separates the many who are
very likely not to have cancer from the small number that may and need
further evaluation.
The two tests actually share this in common.
Sensitivity is the probability that a result
will be positive when the test is applied to a person
with cancer. Specificity is the probability that the test will be
negative when it's applied to a person who does not have cancer.
For convenience and practicality, these measures are defined
and calculated within the boundaries of the screening interval.
In other words, if these adverse events, these different events, haven't happened
within a year or two years or 10 years, then the
original reading is upheld.
And there are fundamental differences between the way these tests work that
mean that we have to think more carefully about how these measures are applied.
So in single cancer early detection tests, test sensitivity is typically
higher. We tend to put a very
high bar on high test sensitivity.
And when test sensitivity is lower, and it can be lower,
if a test is applied on a regular basis, you can focus on what we call
program sensitivity. That is, if we did not detect
the test on the previous round, there's a very good chance we'll detect it on
the subsequent round. If the cancer is relatively slow-growing,
there's no harm. We still have a very favorable prognosis at the time
of diagnosis. So when you compare maybe more
expensive and more complicated tests that are done less frequently with the
less expensive tests we want to do more frequently, we like to compare
program sensitivity because it really levels the playing field.
For specific cancers, sensitivity can vary by protocol.
It can vary by technology, the program, and the operators
in that program. Some tests are very operator-dependent, and the
histology and host characteristics.
So there's a lot of factors that can actually influence measures of sensitivity.
Sensitivity can be improved by quality measures, and it can be improved by
accepting lower specificity. It's commonly asserted
that when specificity goes up, sensitivity goes
down. When specificity goes down,
sensitivity goes up, that they are inversely related.
But that's not strictly true. When you have a test that you can
improve its qualityAnd when it's operator dependent,
say in interpretation, you can actually move sensitivity and
specificity up simultaneously. Now, at the
ragged edges of the very highest rates, yes, there's no free lunch.
An increment in specificity is going to reduce your
sensitivity. But they both can move up together.
Now, in MCED tests, sensitivity is typically lower, and
it varies by individual cancers. It is lower for early-stage disease
and higher for advanced-stage disease.
And we are understanding this today because these tests
detect circulating markers in the bloodstream,
and they tend to be correlated with a larger, more advanced,
and more aggressive tumor. And given the reign of sojourn times, which
we don't understand particularly well, but you can imagine with a large number of
cancers, they're going to have different detectable preclinical phases.
The lower detection of circulating markers for earlier stage cancers
moderates sensitivity for aggregate detection, and that's
normative at this time. There's going to be an interest in looking at how well
these tests perform for the
group of cancers that they're intended to detect.
But we also know how well they perform for individual cancers.
That's mainly an R&D issue, but it also can help us improve the test
performance.
Aggregate and single cancer stage-specific sensitivity will be
influenced by cancer case mix, and that's also
something to have a better understanding of.
If you are challenged to find many of these cancers early, that
sensitivity will be lower. And without very large samples,
it's very important to not draw conclusions about test
performance for lower incidence single cancers.
Statistical power is a critical issue here.
And there's little data on program sensitivity.
We have not had an opportunity to look at the performance of
these tests very often when they've been done year after
year. It's something that we really are looking forward to being able to
see.
Now, these are additional considerations.
There's also the issue of the detection of non-targeted cancer signals.
Now, this can happen in single cancer early detection tests, too.
You've all heard the complaints about incidental findings for screening tests that
use CT. So similar to SCED tests, MCED
tests also will detect cancer signals from non-targeted cancers.
These are cancers without a tissue of origin
predictability, and they'll do this with sufficient sensitivity to
not be uncommon. So should we treat these as true positives
or as false positives?
My sense is that if you've got a cancer signal, we don't want to be
irritated about it. It's not a false positive, but we are
going to want to work it up, and it makes sense to categorize these in an
other category.
The cancer detection rate is important.
Depending upon the population that you're screening,
the mix of your targeted tumors, you would like to know
the number of cancers detected per thousand or per 100,000 to compare this
with registry data, to compare this across different assays,
for the aggregate mix of tumors, and for the individual cancers.
This is a very useful measure of sensitivity, as is how your
test is performing with the predictability of the
first signal for tumor of origin and the second, and
the two combined.
The tissue of origin for most of the assays actually performs
relatively well, as you can see from these numbers here.
Now, an MCED test with moderate aggregate sensitivity will
have a larger public health impact than a higher sensitivity single
cancer early detection test.
After decades of looking at sensitivity and specificity measures for single
cancer, we're sort of primed to expect really, really high
performance in our screening tests.
On the other hand, if we have a significant fraction of cancer
deaths each year attributable to cancers without any
screening strategy, we might reasonably expect except
lower sensitivity to have a bigger impact across a large
number of cancers.
And a modeled effect of one MCED using published site and stage
specific sensitivities and fatality predicted that annual screening
could prevent 17% of cancer deaths in screened
individuals. When you think about the number of cancer deaths each
year,
the person who did this modeling said it would be transformative
and in the presence of a modest sensitivity.
Another thing that we're doing is at this early stage, we're looking at stage
shift as an early endpoint. Now, in many respects, this
makes a great deal of sense. As I said earlier, we understand that the
stage the cancer is diagnosed is strongly
associated with prognosis. And the idea of getting an early
indicator on how a test performs with respect to the
distribution of stage and to the degree that we see a stage shift
is something that's very encouraging.
It actually might give us an opportunity under different modeled
methodologies to introduce these tests earlier
into the population.
But what we need to also recognize is that stage is a pretty blunt
instrument. It's really not very, very specific,
and we really do not, in our judgment, want to hang our
hats on observing a significant stage shift when
we might actually see significant progress within stage groups.
In 2004, and this is, I think, fascinating that we can go back 22
years and find really what I regard as a pathbreaking paper by Elena
Elkin and colleagues who showed that when you looked at the SEER data
and the distribution of tumor characteristics within stage groups
between SEER data and over a
20-year period, there was a substantial within stage
migration of tumor size accounted for in 61%
and 28% of local and regionalized breast cancers, which
translates into much better progress and much better
survival.So I think going forward, we want to make sure that we do
not just put all of our eggs in the one basket of seeing
shifts from just stage four to stage three, three to two, and so on.
Now, these are the terms that you're all familiar with, false
negatives, false positives, true negatives.
These are the actual labels that we apply to what we
get from different levels of sensitivity and specificity.
Negative tests are mostly are true negatives.
Most of the negative tests are true negatives.
Some negative tests are false negatives.
Positive tests mostly are false positives, but some positive tests are
true positives. With our single cancer early detection tests, the
majority of recalls, false positives, actually turn
out not to be cancer.
I think grading the initial outcomes as true or false implies that a
screening test should function as a diagnostic test and that
false outcomes are errors.
Now, if you think about that, if the screening test can't be a
diagnostic test, then why are we
calling referral for further evaluation,
grading it into false positives and false
negatives? We should view screening as a process
of information gathering, as a continuum of information gathering
intended to answer a fundamental question: Does the patient have
cancer?
Now, I'll just give you a kind of an anecdote.
The task force,
our old task force, acknowledged this concept in 2021,
and it actually has led under the Affordable Care Act for follow-up
tests for colorectal cancer to be covered as part of screening.
So reasons for false negative next. You can have human error, no question.
Everybody involved in this field can make mistakes.
Host characteristics contribute to false negatives.
Test limitations can contribute to false negatives.
But a subsequent diagnosis of cancer outside of the screening interval
may render a prior normal finding incorrect.
In contrast, false positives also have these same factors that can
contribute to a, what is commonly called, an error.
Host characteristics, test limitations.
But the
practitioner may simply be concerned about the findings and does
not want to release the patient with a normal test result without
further evaluation. In this instance, recalling the
patient was the correct decision.
It should not be called a false positive.
But a subsequent diagnosis of cancer outside the screening interval may
actually render what was previously a false positive, a correct
answer, and I'll show you the example here.
This is
a risk of an interval colorectal cancer, a risk of being
diagnosed with advanced colorectal cancer, and risk of fatal
cancer in adults with normal test results based upon the
distribution of the adenoma detection rates.
And it took a while to actually identify, in
the longer follow-up period, because we go 10 years between
colonoscopies, that people who had poor adenoma
detection rates compared to good adenoma detection rates, it had significant
consequence for a significant number of patients that had normal test
examinations.
In contrast, what we've seen in a number of studies is that a false
positive,
a breast cancer, a mammogram that was recalled and determined to be
a false positive,
has oftentimes resulted in a cancer,
in subsequent examinations. This is an estimate of the risk of
developing breast cancer after a false positive screening mammogram.
Essentially, the radiologist determined there was something there that they weren't
comfortable with, but they never could really identify a way to work it up in a
way to render a true positive, and yet subsequently, these patients
developed breast cancer. With the AI tools that we're developing
today, these patients are likely to be put into a program of
surveillance. There's nothing to biopsy now, there's nothing you can really do,
but there's something about the pattern of parenchyma that warrants following this
patient closely to determine if they're going to develop breast cancer.
Do MCEDs have a high false positive rate?
Many people believe they do, and it's remarkable.
This is on the web, on the website of a major cancer center
that says it's a very high false positive rate, indicating approximately
1% of adults will have a positive test.
That's a very low false positive rate.
And what it is, is it's the complement of the PPV at biopsy.
So my point is that it's important not to interpret
MCEDs in the context of how we commonly think of single cancer early
detection tests. With MCEDs, test specificity is higher.
The predictive value at biopsy is higher than single cancer early detection
tests. And it remains to be determined how much follow-up time
will be required if you have a positive test without being able to do any
cancer to determine whether or not that original test result actually
was correct, but we do not have the tools yet to find the cancer
through imaging or other ways.
All right, so after more than a half-century evaluation of single cancer early
tests, we still are learning about the nuances of how to think about sensitivity
and specificity and what we label as false positives and
negatives.
MCEDs represent a potential paradigm shift in screening and
a game changer in reducing the cancer burden.
And similar to SCED tests, screening with an MCED test should be
viewed as a process of information gathering rather than a
series of discrete tests. We will face challenges in working up these
tests. Our challenge is to meet those challenges.
MCED performance characteristics and screening outcomes are not directly
analogous to the measures we use for single cancer early detection tests.
MCEDs detect multiple cancers via shared signals.
They may detect more than one cancer signal at a time or detect a
shared cancer signal for a cancer that is not a target of the
test.We need to compare these tests as to how well they
identify tissues of origin or how other
processes for working up a positive finding.
The performance measures and outcomes, as you heard in the introduction, need to be
tailored and interpreted in the context of the unique characteristics of
these tests, and we're not there yet.
But in a world where these two tests are going to coexist,
establishing consistent definitions for true and false positives,
which properly should be called recall for further evaluation,
and the tissue of origin accuracy are critical for comparing tests,
guiding regulatory expectations, and supporting clinical
decision-making. Thank you.
Thanks, everybody.
My name is Nima. I'm a radiation oncologist and a clinical researcher from
Portland, Oregon, and my biases as a clinician will be
readily apparent in my talk.
Waiting on the...
There we go.
Sorry, I was making your job harder by moving the mouse. My bad.
All right. So
today,
thank you, Bree, for tasking me with one of the more nuanced topics.
I appreciate that. I want to focus on a
deceptively simple question.
That is, what exactly is the target condition in multi-cancer early
detection tests? As Bob nicely alluded to, for single
cancer screening, that's usually pretty obvious.
But for MCED tests, that's really not.
And how we answer this question has real consequences for clinicians,
regulators, patients, payers, and developers.
Here are my disclosures.
So in single cancer screening, target conditions are typically defined as a
specific disease entity and a specific use population.
They're usually anchored to a familiar label: breast,
cervical, colorectal, lung. Those USPSTF A and
B labels that we're all used to.
And these cancer screening tests have
defined clinical workflows, confirmatory testing, and
regulatory endpoints all around that same label.
And that alignment is what makes single cancer screening feel intuitive
to clinicians and straightforward for regulators.
But MCEDs really break that traditional model, as Bob also
alluded to. It's because these MCED tests are built on a
shared tumor biology in the blood and not a single
anatomic organ.
Stakeholders still often want organ-by-organ harm-benefit evidence,
but the underlying biology frequently behaves in clusters.
So, traditional screening is defined by the
tool's reach. However, MCEDs are defined by the biology's reach,
and those are not always the same thing.
And this is the root of the target condition problem.
A major part of that confusion is that different stakeholders mean different things
when they say cancer type, just as Tina and Bree alluded to, as far as
creating a common definition in this field.
Pathologists want biologic precision.
They're looking at things like histology, subtype, lineage, biomarkers.
Epidemiologists and regulators
would want to have definitional consistency.
They want to see a reproducible case definition that allows for fair comparison
across studies.
And then me as a clinician, I want management clarity.
I want confidence that the result maps to a clear, evidence-based
next step, and MCEDs sit at the intersection of all three of these.
In my opinion, the target condition in MCED tests cannot be separated
from cancer signal origin.
For MCED tests that utilize methylation-based approaches, the biologic
premise is that the DNA that's shed within the bloodstream has patterns that
reflect both malignancy and tissue of origin.
And with that methylation signature, a cancer signal origin can be
provided to the clinician to help link detection with a predicted diagnostic
pathway.
I plead to the folks in this crowd right now, investigators and developers, to
continue working on these localization efforts for the cancer signal origin.
It's incredibly helpful for me as the end user, incredibly helpful for the
patients as well. Detection alone is not enough.
The field needs to keep pushing toward this localization.
Across multiple data sets, cancer signal origin is accurate enough to be
clinically useful as a workup diagnostic tool, a workup directing tool,
and I myself have experience with that as well.
The key point here is that just the PPV is not meaningful, but that
the CSO accuracy is consistently high enough to help
narrow the diagnostic search. And this shifts MCEDs from being
a vague screening signal to a clinically actionable starting point.
I think one way to think about the target condition grouping is biologic parity.
Some CSOs reflect embryologic, molecular,
or histologic
relationships more so than strict organ boundaries.
Examples of this include HPV tumors, hematologic cancers,
neuroendocrine cancers, and soft tissue carcinomas.
So if the biology clusters naturally, it may make more
sense to evaluate some targets in biologic families
rather than forcing them into rigid anatomic
boxes.A second
way, and in many ways, a more pragmatic approach, is grouping
by clinical workup parity.
Here, the target condition is defined by the diagnostic pathway it
triggers. The important idea is that the harm of the workup may be
relatively fixed. For example, one CT may evaluate multiple
CSOs in a single scan,
and in turn, the diagnostic yield rises as you consider the cluster.
This is why pathway-based grouping may be more clinically honest than
cancer by cancer splitting in many MCED settings.
So how should regulators, clinicians, and payers compare these MCED technologies?
Again, I believe not just by an aggregate sensitivity or number of cancer
types detected, but
comparing these tests on common units, and those
units may be the biologic reach, CSO accuracy,
diagnostic pathway efficiency, workup burden, or actionable yield.
And this is all because regulators need interpretable and reproducible target
condition definitions, clinicians and patients need confidence that the result
maps to a workable diagnostic pathway, and payers need evidence that the
downstream workup burden is justified by yield and value.
So this is the part of my talk where it becomes pretty clinical.
So I apologize for those of you in the crowd who
potentially
may see the bias in my talk coming in as a physician.
The CSO is not just a navigational tool, it changes how we
interpret indeterminate findings.
Indeterminate findings are everywhere in medicine.
I see them every day in my practice.
And in an average risk patient, many of them are watched conservatively, the
don't worry about it approach.
But when a subtle abnormality matches the CSO
from a positive MCED result, the post-test probability and
malignancy changes, and that alignment can justify moving from the don't
worry about it approach to more aggressive diagnostic action.
And these principles have been shaped by real experience at OHSU.
Across nearly 10,000 tested individuals and more than 100 signal-positive workups,
our team has learned a great deal about how these MCED tests
perform in practice and how the cancer signal origin can
influence clinical management. And these next few cases illustrate that.
This is a participant. Again, these next participants are all asymptomatic,
no symptoms on presentation, receiving a multi-cancer early detection test for
cancer screening. They had a positive test with a cancer signal origin for head and
neck cancer. One of the initial diagnostic pathways in these
scenarios is send these patients to our head and neck colleagues.
They did a full workup, including nasopharyngeal laryngoscopy, all
the way down to the larynx. No mucosal disease was seen.
The next step in the workup was to get a CT of the neck, which revealed a
sub-centimeter left neck lymph node identified here.
Lymph nodes throughout the body are incredibly common, and many times we go the
don't worry about it conservative approach.
However, because of the signal-positive test and the CSO that matched
this indeterminate finding in the scan,
and because my colleagues had some
experience working with these MCED tests, we were able to take the next step
to do a neck dissection to further confirm this lymph node.
This was too deep and inaccessible for FNA biopsy.
And indeed, it returned to be an HPV positive head and neck cancer
of unknown primary, and patient has received definitive chemoradiation.
Again, turning indeterminate findings into aggressive action for this
patient.
Here's another asymptomatic patient who had a cancer signal origin for a lymphoid
malignancy, and part of that initial workup for any lymphoma is a whole-body
PET CT, which revealed a single FDG-avid lymph node in the
left groin. Again, this is something, as a radiation oncologist, I see all
the time in my practice and many times chalk it up to something reactive and
benign. However, because it matched the CSO
finding,
a very skilled radiologist was able to do a core needle biopsy, ultimately
revealing a stage one follicular lymphoma, and the patient has received curative
low-dose radiation for that.
This is another interesting case of a patient who many years
ago had a gastric bypass surgery, and this will become relevant here in a little
bit, who had a
MCED test positive for a gastric or esophageal origin.
We sent him to our gastroenterology colleagues. The upper endoscopy was normal.
However, because of the gastric bypass surgery, they were unable to
traverse and access the distal two-thirds of the stomach.
Before deeming this patient as a false positive, we got a PET CT.
PET CT showed some avidity within the antrum
of the stomach, the portion that was bypassed from his surgery
previously. And again, FDG avidity of
gastrointestinal organs is something we see all the time in practice.
This is a highly metabolically organ, and more cases than
not, they are followed expectantly or ignored.
But again, because it matched the CSO,
we had evidence to proceed into the operating room under general
anesthesia to perform a double balloon enteroscopy.
This is an advanced procedure that our endoscopy colleagues performed,
where a very long endoscope is looped into the small intestine
and back into the bypass portion of the stomach.
Biopsy ultimately revealing a gastric adenocarcinoma in patient receiving
curative chemotherapy and surgery.
This next case is clinically interesting and maybe unsettling,
based on
your take. This is a patient, again, who had a
lymphoid signal origin finding.
PET CT, again, a whole body PET CT was normal, was
negative. No subtle abnormalities for us to chase.
This patient was also seen by ENT because they also had a
nasal polyp that we wanted to make sure wasn't a lymphoma. That was benign.
One year later, they presented with throat pain.And further
workup revealed a diffuse large B-cell lymphoma of the head and
neck, a Stage 2 diffuse large B-cell lymphoma originating in the tonsil.
And this case illustrates that
even though some cases may be deemed false positive and they may be
clinically occult on imaging, they may require
longitudinal follow-up because some patients may actually progress with the cancer
detected by these MCED tests. And how to identify those patients
are way out of my wheelhouse right now.
This last case is not a patient who had an MCED test, but I think
it's illustrative for many reasons.
This is a patient from our liver tumor board.
And I had no business with this case, and I had my microphone muted, but just kind
of thinking to myself, this is a patient who had a
hepatocellular carcinoma found on ultrasound screening because they had high risk
of cancer because of their cirrhosis. It was biopsy proven.
The fantastic PCP that found this cancer was trying
to speed up his workup as he was seeing oncology and ordered a
PET-CT. PET-CT is not a common diagnostic workup for
hepatocellular carcinomas, especially for well-differentiated ones.
They just don't take up the PET tracer.
And you can see on this PET-CT for this patient, a kind of
heterogeneous uptake in the liver here.
And this portion of uptake here is the duodenum, and
just physiologic uptake in the duodenum.
Some heterogeneity, maybe something here, maybe something here.
But really not enough to call anything.
When the patient came to OHSU, we knew that they needed some
focused workup for HCC, which includes a multiphasic
MRI. And a liver-specific
multiphasic MRI revealed two obvious hepatic masses, quite
large, that were pretty inapparent on the PET-CT.
So this just, I think, drives the point home that even though you have a CSO
and even though you've imaged the organ, you might not be
providing the right imaging test for the patient. And the CSO really helped us.
And I thought to myself in tumor board, if this patient had an MCED test
without that CSO finding, I probably would've blown right through an HCC.
So in summary, I think the real target condition as a clinician, in
my opinion, is a clinically actionable cancer signal that's
linked to a diagnostic pathway.
I believe that MCED tests should not always be judged cancer subtype by subtype,
and the true value of the cancer signal origin is its ability to change clinical
management by turning uncertainty into action.
And these precise target condition definitions, again, the work of
the Blood PAC committee, are foundational for valid interpretation
across technical, clinical, regulatory, and reimbursement stakeholders.
Here's a picture that I took on my phone up from our medical
center at Oregon Health & Science University.
This is the Portland Aerial Tram, transports
patients,
employees, such as myself, and tourists from the Willamette River up to the
medical center.
Please feel free to contact me. Thank you.
Thank you so much to the organizers and an engaged audience.
I'm very much looking forward to the panel discussion and visiting
Portland one of these days.
I'll be talking about implementation considerations for MCED
and single cancer early detection tests, and you'll
hear some of the same themes, but giving it a slightly different
context. These are my disclosures.
So, in the next 10 or 12 minutes, I'll frame the issues
around generalizability, how we go from trial data to real-world
application, and what this implies for
implementation in different patient populations and settings.
Strategies to address generalizability, what can we do about this, and
then leave you with some summary points.
So let's frame the problem. Trial populations differ
systematically from intended screening populations.
I'm sure that's a broad statement, but all of you will agree that,
again, trial conditions are very different from when we
apply it to our screening population, and that's true for most clinical trials.
And we see some very interesting results from real-world application.
In some cases, we see literally a flipped pattern in
certain conditions. So these differences going from
trials to real-world application really shape the
benefit-harm balance. And hence, do we use the test?
How much we use it, and
what do we do as a follow-up for the test?
But generalizability is what we're after.
That's the intent of the trials as they're designed for clinical
validation and also helps us guide implementation
decisions.
However,
trial doesn't automatically mean intended screening
population. So there's always some give and take that we have
to adjust for. And the idea is we want to get
them as close as possible because obviously we want our clinical
validation to reflect what it would look like when we apply it to the
general population and our patients from different settings.
I see patients in three different settings.
At the academic medical center, a very different population, much more
educated, very few risk factors, and pretty healthy.
I see patients at VA, a veteran population.
Again,
older,
enriched with risk factors. And I also practice at a federally qualified
healthcare center in Brooklyn, a very different population.
Many of them, it's literally their first time that they're seeking healthcare.
So you can see the application automatically gets very different when we think of
the population.So again, there's direct implications for
population-level benefits, because again, when I'm looking at my
whole healthcare system, I want to see a population-level benefit that
includes some of these subpopulations.
And then this has implications for health equity, as I just alluded to, because
we want these tests to not only be developed on all kinds of
populations, but also be applicable and helpful the same way in
different patient populations.
So let's look at a few things that happen in trials,
which make them look either better or worse than what we see in reality.
As it was alluded to, there's often age
enrichment. Many trials will actually supplement the trials with
older age groups, enrich with more cancers.
There's stage enrichment, as we commonly see with higher stage cancers
because the signal is more easier to detect or there's more tumor shedding.
Cancer known cases are often tossed in, again, to increase
the diagnosis. And this leads
to some non-representative prevalence in the trial population, which
is not reflective necessarily of the populations that we're going to apply them to.
And again, these things are done because otherwise the trials would be
50,000, 60,000 individuals, would take 10s and 20s of
years to complete. So we have to do something to
increase that cancer signal, but then it comes with a cost.
So the impacts of these enrichment strategies are threefold.
One, as you can imagine, if we enrich them with
high-risk individuals or more cancers, we essentially get an
inflated positive predictive value because, again, it's a
non-representative prevalence population.
That also means there's a lower apparent false positive burden
compared to a general population with a lower prevalence.
So then the relevance to an asymptomatic low-prevalence
population, such as the one I described first,
becomes somewhat difficult to generalize.
So I'll give you some examples, and again, there's many.
So this was the first. This is a stool-based test, not a
blood-based test. This is the Cologuard test that we currently use,
FDA-approved, Medicare-approved,
and fully commercialized for the last 10 years.
This was the pivotal study,
very ahead of its time,
12 years ago now. And even this trial, and
this is the trial based on which the test got both FDA and Medicare approval
at the same time, which is unheard of for any other test,
and no test has since been able to do that.
Even this trial
enrolled, and this was almost 10,000 individuals across the US.
Enrollment was weighted towards persons 65 years of age or older
in order to increase the prevalence of cancer. So you see this very commonly.
It was just one line embedded in the methods, and I don't even think people in the
field actually know that this was done or what implications it
has. So clearly, in these next 12 years, we've had the
opportunity to study
the performance at a population level, and that may not
necessarily be the same as what we saw in this trial, and you could suspect
why.
On the converse, trial population may be at lower risk
for cancer than your intended use population.
And that's because if you think about a clinical validation study
where we ask asymptomatic individuals without any
known cancers to enroll in the study, and that's what we enroll,
there's a healthy volunteer bias.
We already know they don't have any existing cancers.
There's also a selection bias.
People that sign up generally are motivated, they're healthy, their lifestyles are
healthier, and their baseline cancer risk is lower.
They tend to be non-smokers, mostly women,
and just healthy overall. So we could actually, we think we're
enrolling
an intended use population, but we could actually end up enrolling a
lower risk population.
And this was apparent. So we are part of the NCI-funded
consortium called Early Detection Research Network.
It's a prospective multi-center study, and we collect
blood, stool, and other biospecimens from average-risk individuals to
validate different cancers. In 29 geographically
dispersed study sites, very carefully selected to represent, we think,
generalizability in different populations across the US, Canada, and Germany.
And,
we published, and this consortium has been going on for about 15 years.
We published our results mainly for colorectal cancer,
and we had 10 cancers in 5,291
asymptomatic individuals.
So the prevalence rate was 0.2%. If you look at SEER,
the prevalence rate of colorectal cancer in the US population is
0.7% to 1%. So you can see we were very, very under
target compared to SEER. And SEER is not average
risk or intended use because SEER consists of
a mixed bag. It has people that are, at any time, they're probably
symptomatic.
They probably have family histories.
There's probably some asymptomatic, but they may have variable risk factors.
So that's not the population that we pick when we do these
clinical studies. But obviously, we're not going to take all comers.
We're going to take people without cancers that don't have symptoms.
So you see where it can actually mislead
the prevalence at the population level.
All right. So how can we overcome this?
So some ways to enhance generalizability, and again, I hope we can continue
this in our discussion because there's no one perfect
answer.A fairly straightforward
approach is age and sex adjustment to the US census
population. So this at least gets at the age and sex
distribution because we said cancers are increase in
prevalence with age. Age continues to be the strongest risk factors
for many cancers, including colorectal cancers.
So in the PREEMPT study, which is the clinical
validation of the Freenome test, SimpleScreen, the blood
test for colorectal cancer,
very recently, after publishing that study, we actually did
apply age and sex adjustment, just to show how different it
was. So remind you, the study enrolled almost 50,000
individuals. The clinical validation cohort was
27,000.
You would think at 27,000 individuals, any
differences would wash out. Actually, that's not true.
So in this graph, you see the PREEMPT CRC population
from 201 centers in the US, with great pains
taken to enhance generalizability.
You can see how it stacks up to the US population for age and sex distribution.
So clearly, we had more 50 to 54-year-olds in PREEMPT compared to the
US population,
and then fewer older than 75 individuals.
We also had more women. Again, that healthy volunteer bias
comes in than the US population. So we adjusted it, and then we said,
"Okay, how does the performance of the test change?"
So this is how the test performance changed.
So, in the first column, you see the performance
of the test original without unadjusted, what we reported
in our JAMA paper. And then in the last column, you see after
this
age and sex adjustment. So you can see everything moves a little bit, and
that's because the population kind of moves towards
older and male. So the overall CRC sensitivity
actually goes up from 79.2 to 81.1, which at
27,000 plus individuals is a change.
The stage one
CRC sensitivity goes up from 57 to 63%,
and then the specificity actually goes down a little bit from
91.5% to 90%.
Sensitivity for advanced precursor lesion also goes up from
12.5% to 13.7%. So you can see
this adjustment does make a difference, and if all the tests
did similar adjustments, at least we'd have a little bit of a
apples-to-apples comparison, but there's more nuance here.
And the nuance is this: so, age and sex is one thing, but
it's very crude. Obviously, we'd love to adjust by every
other factor,
such as you just heard, size of the tumor correlates with how much
it's shed. So not all stage one cancers are created equal.
Not all APLs are created equal. So
the distribution of those different categories within that
stage actually make a difference.
So should we also adjust for size and
perhaps location of cancer?
Perhaps, there's a difference in detection by where the cancer is
located,
which again, is a daunting task, but you can see where the
heterogeneity might come in between different studies and between trial
data and real-world applications.
This advanced precursor lesion, we've created this catchall bucket,
and not every category we throw in there is created equal.
So for instance, advanced adenomas with high-grade dysplasia probably
represent the most important lesion in this advanced precursor lesion group.
It doesn't carry the same risk of cancer as
another category in the APL bucket is 5 to 10 non-advanced
adenomas. So frequency doesn't equal histology and so
forth. There's several other categories in there, such as villous histology,
sessile serrated lesions, and they're all very different.
We like to lump them, but essentially, they're very different.
So what happens when in a trial you have a certain distribution, but then when you
go to apply it to your population, there's a very different distribution, and how
does that change the test performance?
So it's hard to adjust for, but something to look at.
One solution here is at least to give or report out the
sensitivity or the performance of the test by each category of that
APL. But again, the numbers start getting smaller, and you're not really
powered to look at those differences. So that caveat comes in.
So no good answers. So that's for single cancer detection tests.
In case of MCADs, again, not all stages are created equal,
and you heard that in the previous talks also.
So a stage three cancer is an all-encompassing bucket.
And for many cancers, stage 3A versus stage 3B has
very different meaning for the oncologist, for the patient,
for their five-year survival, and the treatments we can offer them.
So lumping them in just stage three obviously doesn't do it justice, and
we might need to kind of tease out the subtypes even in that
one big bucket. So we may have to think about
sub-stages of cancers or even
histologic clusters within them.
Another way is for all these tests to report out their
likelihood ratios.
For a clinician, a likelihood ratio is a very valuable thing.
It essentially, as we all said, these tests are not diagnostic.
So what it does is it essentially tells you, it's a risk
stratification tool.
Your post-test probability that this is something worrisome, that
it should warrant imaging, biopsy, or something more aggressive, or close
follow-up. And so these are tremendously helpful, and I think
reporting these and looking for these is really important.
So likelihood of a positive test or a negative test really have value.
So does the number needed to screen or
how many tests need to be done to
actually get to one diagnostic pathway.
So just to illustrate, say, the population prevalence of colorectal cancer is at
0.5% for everybody.Now, if
the likelihood ratio of a positive test for
colorectal cancer,
say, is at
85% or 90%, it increases my post-test probability
by about fivefold, which is meaningful.
I think that patient will need to go to testing.
And similarly, say the specificity is at 90%,
and if the test is negative, now I can reassure the patient that their risk
compared to what I consider a population
average risk is now down to less than 0.1%.
So I really don't need to do further diagnostic testing.
So likelihood ratios from
a test are a good way to then understand which diagnostic pathway
to launch them on.
So what evidence do we need? Prospective population-based cohorts, representative
samples with clear intended use, and then, of course, cancer
diagnosis versus the utility, which is incidence,
mortality. Do they improve other things like health-related quality of
life and system-level outcomes is what we need.
So again, applying that REAIM framework, which
takes a test from testing to implementation, you can
see what happens in the real-world screening data
versus the trial population here, and essentially what we need
to get to a more population-level
implementation generalizability.
So my take-home message is MCED study design might reflect
intended use population, must reflect intended use population
to enhance its generalizability to the extent possible.
Trial enrichment does drive optimistic estimates.
Adjustments to US census for age, sex distribution is very important, I think
should be the minimum bar that we all use.
Real-world data truly then must guide implementation decisions, and we
need layers of that data. Thank you so much.
Hello. That was a
fantastic
dance with data, rolling in the deep of clinical trials
and how they should be validated.
I really enjoyed some of the presentations up to now.
My name is Anand Pathak. I'm a medical officer in the FDA Center for
Devices.
I'd like to present here just six brief points
regarding considerations for MCED performance
evaluation. Point one, the study population
should reflect the context of use.
The foundation of any meaningful performance evaluation
begins with the simple but profound question, does your study
population reflect the intended use population of the device?
In general, the pivotal study
should reflect the intended use population in terms of the age,
sex, race, and ethnicity, and clinical
characteristics of the subjects, such
that the data realistically represents the performance
of the device's context of use and does
not use unrepresentative data
that does not have external generalizability to the target
population.
Point two, design away the bias. The study
design is a critical aspect to consider for MCED
studies. Based on our experience, prospective
cohort studies minimize the risk of spectrum bias
that often
plague
retrospective case control study designs.
There's generally overestimation of performance in studies
using such case control studies.
Even
within prospective cohort studies, however, there may
be problems with the estimation and metrics.
Sensitivity may not adequately be measured, and also
NPV and specificity can be distorted due to
verification bias, where the patients with positive results
receive rigorous investigation while the patients with negative
results do not receive the same workup.
There are statistical techniques to deal with these biases, however.
By and large, PPV is less effective, or the positive
predictive value is less effective
by this specific bias in prospective studies and is an important
metric that is largely determined by prevalence
and specificity, especially in the low-prevalence setting.
In addition to these key metrics for clinical validity,
there are many other metrics that may be considered
for the evaluation of MCED devices, which also
include the accuracy of tissue origin
determination, which
Dr. Nema
went through in great detail when it works.
The goal is simple. The study design should give us the cleanest and
most accurate assessment of the actual performance of the test,
unobscured
by methodological artifacts or poorly thought-out study
designs.
Though prospective unbiased studies may be ideal, we
recognize that there are many situations and many factors
that may justify
alternative approaches. For example, for rare
diseases, flexible approaches may be necessary
to ensure that innovative tests can be
madeAvailable to the public,
and that innovators
are encouraged to come up with proposals to validate such
tests for such populations with unmet need.
Point three: the dual lens, per cancer and overall
performance.
An important consideration for evaluating MCED tests
include the assessment of cancer type-specific performance
and overall performance. We need per cancer
performance and per cancer stage specific performance data
actually to adequately
understand the probable
clinical benefit for specific malignancies.
This is because each cancer and cancer stage can
have different natural histories, treatment paradigms, and
different treatment
clinical implications.
But we also need overall performance, which is an important metric.
And in an ideal situation, we should have data across all
patients with cancer to calculate the overall
sensitivity. And in cancer-free individuals, we should
assess the overall
specificity for non-cancers, which is also a very important
metric.
I just want to talk about the false positivity rate.
Again, it's very important and is largely determined by the
PPV that reflects how many people
without cancer will face unnecessary anxiety,
I'm alluding to the false positives, and diagnostic procedures
which represents the unnecessary diagnostic odyssey, which
is one of the key risks of this device.
And I think Nima and also
Dr. Smith mentioned that maybe even
protracted workups would be necessary because you may have findings
at a further point in time. Point number four,
subgroup analysis. Performance metrics that don't account for subgroups
may give misleading estimates of the test's
performance.
The
key performance metrics at as much as possible and practical
sensitivity, specificity, PPV, NPV,
likelihood ratios should all be stratified by age group,
cancer type, and stage, and relevant clinical and
demographic factors.
And finally, point number six: where is the tumor?
Here's where multi-cancer
early detection or detection fundamentally diverges from single
cancer screening. A positive test result is just the
beginning of the odyssey. The tissue of origin
performance is not a secondary consideration, it's a critical metric
that contributes to the potential clinical benefit.
Two important questions to ask are, can the test detect
cancer? And the second is, among the detected cancers,
can it correctly identify where the cancer is?
And there are multiple modalities to determine tissue of origin
as well. So let me not forget to mention that.
However, tissue of origin accuracy, though it can
help a clinical workup greatly in patients as
the examples by Nima show. When the TLO is
incorrect, patients may undergo diagnostic
procedures targeting the wrong organ, potentially delaying
the correct diagnosis. And when applied to the
population scale, this may become a
problem.
Across all of these, beyond looking at the individual patient,
you can also think about what these performance metrics when
measured to the highest standards impact the
overall population.
And finally, I like to discuss my point
number seven it seems. The balance.
This is an extra point. I'm including it extra for you
guys.
Bonus.
This is a bonus. So the final thing is weighing probable
benefits
versus probable risks. First of all, as I said,
there's a dual lens and actually there are multiple lenses.
But one of the lenses is to look at this balance at
the overall level. And the other lens is
actually to look at the probable benefit
across cancer types and stages because the
probable benefit may not be the same for every cancer
type that a MCED can detect. It's a nuanced
calculation that depends on the biology, the treatment options,
and the natural history of the disease at the particular cancer
type and stage.
The benefit-risk calculus should also be cancer specific
as far as possible.
But potential risks must also be considered.
There are a long list of risks. However, key risks that
we may talk about right now are the harms of unnecessary
diagnostic workups for false positives.
Whether or not they're unnecessary, I guess time will determine.
And next, actually very salient, is the risk of false
reassurance for the false negatives, which may be different for
cancers that have standard of care screening versus cancers that don't.
And these are only two risks among many other risks that
we will discuss
in the future.
These are just very tacit, clear points about
how
... critical metrics, though they may seem
very generic and
like almost meaningless, are actually extremely
important when they're actually measured correctly.
So I'm an advocate for getting the right population
and getting the right study design to get the right measurement for
evaluation of the probable benefit and the probable risk.
Thank you.
So thank you so much to our speakers. We would love to take some questions.
So if you do have questions, please speak up, go up to the microphones that are
here. And while people are contemplating their questions,
I will ask the first one. So Gary, this is for you.
Yes.
Nima talked about his experience with MSKID, which is really in a
tertiary academic setting. And I'm curious if you
have thoughts about how this experience can translate to the
community practice.
What does the field need to do to support or enable that transition, and how should
we be thinking about this as it becomes more broadly applicable?
Yes, thank you so much. I should probably give some just quick
background. For the National Minority Quality Forum, we have been working
with MD Anderson and Quest Diagnostic to essentially
create some living labs in communities that have been
exposed to environmental toxins.
Cancer Alley in Louisiana, Fifth Ward in Houston, Texas, Flint, Michigan, et
cetera. These are communities that have an elevated risk for cancer.
And oddly enough, we have no medical protocols at all
for assessing environmental risks for cancer.
We took these MSKIDs on because
the thing that, for us, that was most important about them was that they
allowed us to surveil at the population level.
If you think about a colonoscopy, if you think about a
CT scan, or even a mammogram, you can't
surveil the population using those tools, and these liquid
biopsies and other tools like that allow us to do that.
And so what we're searching for is
what we would call pre-symptomatic cancer.
Can we find cancer way upstream? Because
that's what these communities have. They get diagnosed late for cancer.
They're not in clinical studies. There's no medical protocol, et cetera.
And what we're trying to do is understand that.
And we're doing it tied to reimbursement models as well.
So it's at this intersection of understanding the clinical,
but also understanding what's going on at the reimbursement side of
it. I love the science.
My doctorate's actually in history. I like to always confess that.
This is where germ theory was in the 19th century.
You have opened up a new portal to understand
disease way up its natural history, and it's
exciting. And if you go into the communities that we work in, this
is their future. This is what they're truly excited about.
And so we're collecting a lot of that data.
A lot of the questions that you're asking here in terms of
subpopulation analysis, how to screen, when to screen, who
to screen, all of those kinds of questions we're trying to get answers for
in these communities that, quite frankly, nobody's looking at.
There isn't the kind of study going on.
So, I would just end here to say
this is the future. I think by the time we get to 2050,
the science and technology is just going to be fabulous, and I congratulate all of
the scientists and the hard work and even the regulatory folks
understanding how we bring all of this to the American public. Thanks.
Is it okay if I make one more point? Thank you so much, Gary.
That was a really valuable perspective.
I would say in our experience,
in the state of Oregon, Oregon's quite a rural state, and we have
lots of communities that are underserved.
On the clinical trials that we participated on, we've had some
standout subsites within the community.
One to name is Coos Bay on the
southern coast of Oregon, and it's a very underserved area, high cancer prevalence.
Getting the test to patients didn't seem like a barrier, especially now with
mobile phlebotomy approaches.
But the barrier that I see is actually having somebody within the
community to provide that clinically actionable next
step. As well as all of the
diagnostic tools needed to adjudicate these tests as
well. For instance, that one case I showed with that complex endoscopy, you could
only get that in Portland. So being able to have a lifeline to the
tertiary academic center to escalate signal positives with providers in the
community that have some familiarity with the test and
connections with other folks in the bigger city, I think is really, really
important.
Thank you.
Hi. Yeah.
Go for it.
Mike Gimura. Full disclosure, I was an investigator in the GRAIL Pathfinder too,
so at least it's led me to think about some of these things.
And two comments. One is, I didn't hear any comments about
lead time bias in terms of making the diagnosis, but not necessarily
affecting the long-term outcome.
And two, I think one of the benefits that wasn't addressed of these tests
is the relative low compliance of things like
colonoscopy, where 50% of the population don't get their
colonoscopies as recommended. So these tests, even if they're
not perfect, may help. You say, well, we're not going to pick
up more colon cancers, but we may be able to get better
compliance if it's a blood test as opposed to the
hurdles to get a colonoscopy or even a low-dose CT scan and things like that.
Thank you.
Do you want to comment?
No.
Maybe try that one.
Okay.
We don't have a system of healthcare.
We don't have organized cancer screening, and so we are constantly
struggling not only to get everybody
screened, but everybody screened regularly.And one of the biggest
problems we have is for people who get non-colonoscopy tests, if
it's a positive test, getting it followed up.
HEDIS is going to have a performance measure that essentially is going to
act on the
fact that if you have had a positive test and it hasn't been worked up, then you
haven't had a complete screening test.
So I hope that will help also. We also
rather want to segregate MCEDs and single
cancer tests because they're supposed to serve different functions.
But in the absence of regular adherence and with quality
problems, invariably we're going to pick up cancers on MCEDs
that we would've hoped we'd have picked up on single cancer tests.
And I think for the time being, that's not an altogether bad thing.
We'll go over there.
Okay. Testing. Hi, Avery Nikolai from Natera.
I have a question for Dr. Nabavi Zadeh.
So I got from your talk that the primary helpfulness of MSAD
tests is it allows you to physically locate the cancer and thus compare it
against scans. Are other pieces of
information, such as subtype or really anything else you can think of,
also helpful, or would those really be of just limited usefulness
compared to just getting that physical location?
Yeah, absolutely. Great question. Thank you for that question.
I don't think it's specifically connected to scans.
For instance, just this last week, we identified an early-stage anal cancer, and
that patient
needed an anoscopy to prove that that was the case.
And subsequent scans happened because they needed to get their cancer staged, but
it's really the diagnostic procedures in general.
Now, whether
it was an anal squam versus a much more anal adeno
is insignificant in this diagnostic workup.
Anal adenos are very unusual and very rare.
So, I mean, for me, the clinically actionable
situation is the disease organ and the site.
And, again, using that liver cancer
example, it's not only about examining the organ, but knowing what type
of test that organ needs to have the most sensitivity to find a cancer in that
organ.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Question for probably the three, the whole table.
Bruno Douz from Gustave Roussy in Paris.
More of a challenge of the 1% false positive rates being a low number,
because if we think about 67, 68 million people living
in those countries, this would reflect in almost 700,000
people who potentially undergo fancy balloons or
endoscopic assessment and potentially excisional biopsies or
image-guided biopsies, that most of health systems could not absorb that
number. So until we find the perfect test or until we have the
perfect test, shouldn't we spend more time addressing what to do with those
patients who kind of positive and maybe first assessment level is
not clarifying enough?
The communities that I work in,
you're talking about 50% of the
households have had cancer in the household.
You're talking about
people who don't get to see their young children because they're
dying at the age of 60.
You're talking about
mothers and fathers whose child
has contracted cancer at the age of 11 or 12.
This
science here permits us to go into those communities and
begin to do those screenings. And this is why I think risk assessing is
incredibly important and why environmental risk assessing
is important.
We have 125 million Americans who live in an
environmentally toxic environment.
I mean, that's the fact. And their rate for
cancer is very, very high,
and their mortality rates are high because they get diagnosed late.
So,
I kind of get it that we need to do a lot of
good science here.
But I think there's a way to think about the moment that we're
in and bringing this science and technology to those
communities in some fashion or form.
I tell my staff all the time, the Wright brothers flew for 59
seconds.
That's what the Wright brothers did.
And we're in that 59-second position with this technology.
And yes, we can wait for the perfect, but there are going to be a lot of people
who are not going to be around if we do that, and that would be my
response.
All right, I'm going to move us along.
Over there.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Daria Chudo of Garden Health.
The discussion about generalizability is obviously very important.
I want us to be considering that very carefully, though, in the context of
trials where screening population is large, but the cancers
are very rare. And when we talk about adjustment for age or
gender in a population of 70 cancers or so, we're really facing
significant statistical challenges on the power and interpretation of that data.
So that's concern one. Concern two is we all know that detectability
is primarily driven by cancer stage and lesion size, and all of these
variables control the amount of shedding.
And so when we talk about demographic adjustments without
accompanying analysis of what it means from a clinical known factor
perspective,
I'm not sure how to interpret that data.
So while I agree with Anand about stratifying by all these variables to
understand the performance to the extent we can, I don't think there's power in
the data we have to make any judgments based on the adjusted data.
So I just want us to exercise a lot of caution with small sample sizes that are
involved here when we interpret all of this.
Well, let me speak to this since I have experience with this.
Actually, Dr. Schulke is right on point.
I mean, at some point, especially if you have a
demographic
or other factors in your trial that doesn't reflect the
intended use population, just like we did in the Guardian Shield device,
you can adjust for age, at least in prevalence.
Those are two things that can be easily adjusted for, and we did that for
the Guardian Shield. For the MCED,
the actual methodology for adjustment may be much more
complex. Because every cancer has a different prevalence.
But that's something
that we will have to think about as we proceed.
Because if you want comparability across all these assays, then
maybe
you need to have
this type of age standardization.
The standardization for the
prevalence and
a lot of other things should be aligned.
Like the study design and the way
the intended use and the target population is defined.
Absolutely. It's just sometimes it's going to be, where did
you happen to have early-stage cancers and small cancers, in which age
groups, and when it's only this many cancers.
Yeah.
It's hard to interpret. I agree it's needed to try to align the data,
but really hard to do in practice.
Yeah. So that's a challenge that is in front of us. But also as Dr.
Bob Smith said, even within the same stage, as you
know from The Guardian Shield, there may be
changes in the size of the tumor, right?
Mm-hmm.
That's also a very important variable-
Absolutely
... to look at.
Yep. I agree with that.
All right. I think we're going to let Tom have the last question.
I have a question to anyone on the panel or the whole panel,
about how we think about
reporting results in aggregate across a broad range of cancer types
versus by cancer type and by stage.
And just the context for that question is just a little bit of mental
math. If you study 100,000 people
of general risk
for a year, you'll get 1,000 cancers.
An MCED with a 50% sensitivity might pick up
500 of them.
That's maybe 50 cases of
prostate cancer if you studied only men.
And once you get past the top three, four, or five cancers,
you're going to have
10, 15 examples of a cancer. Break
that down by stage, you're talking about two or three cases.
So,
I struggle to, other than descriptive statistics, I
struggle how we might report
meaningful data by cancer type and by stage across a
broad range of cancer types from a prospective study.
We can do that in a case control study, but then you've got spectrum
bias and other challenges. So if we could explore that further
as a panel, I'd very much appreciate that.
Tom.
Yeah. I think it's a really important question, and it
raises the issue of what do we mean by
we want to report both. It implies that
the report of the individual cancers would be meaningful.
And as you've described in the context of low statistical power,
it could be interesting, but it's not clear what meaning you can draw from it
until you have larger samples.
So in general, calls to deaggregate these results as if each
is equally meaningful, I think is not
correct. I think the aggregate results are the point of an
MCED. The individual cancers to tell you how they're
contributing to that aggregate result is an R&D
issue. It's an interesting issue, but I don't think
it's the basis for judging the performance of the test because it's going to have
aggregate features as well.
Yeah. I completely agree with you, Tom.
I've overseen thousands of MCED
tests now and have only worked up nearly 100, and
I'm still learning from every case.
And everything that the end clinician is doing with this result is
feeding into the metrics of the test, namely the positive
predictive value. How aggressively is the clinician looking?
How
complete is the diagnostic
weaponry around that clinician to adjudicate that cancer?
And there's just so many downstream variables with all
these metrics, especially once you're getting cancer type by cancer type, that is
just really challenging to define in a prospective setting.
Amia.
I absolutely agree with you. So
then you could move from
kind of the diagnostic
performance to clinical utility.
Where you can say, okay, we said these tests aren't
really as such diagnostic. They're part of a cascade or a
pathway or a strategy of screening.
So maybe we could compare populations where we do usual care, not do
anything, wait for those 1,000 cancers.
And then we have another group. So we randomize two patient populations, and
in the second group, we administer this test, see what catching those
500 early cases does or changes. And that's
exactly the NHS-Galeri study, which
obviously has reported its results, and we're waiting to see.
There's a lot of rich data there. So I think those kinds of studies will
inform how this strategy unleashed at a population level.
We start to get a signal of how that might change population benefit.
Also, as you mentioned, not all cancers are created equal, and we
have compelling data that necessarily stage shift
doesn't really help many cancers because of lead time and length time
bias. So then you actually then further drill down into your
500 cancers.
... into the ones that we're catching them at an earlier stage or smaller
size actually makes a difference in their outcome.
And obviously, prostate is not one of them, even though we'll see a lot.
But the other big hitters, lung, colon, breast, there we do
have good data that catching them early does seem to change the natural
history. But again, then comparing it to a population that doesn't have all of
this, such as the NHS-Galeri. So I myself am very excited to hear
or see the detailed results of that trial.
Yeah. Dr. Beer, I think you asked a very insightful question.
Yeah, it is a challenge when you have very low numbers
in certain cancers. But I think this is the type of context
where
nimble thinking, alternative approaches to
characterize may come into play. But other than that, I
can just say and repeat what
Dr. Bob Smith said, that you also have aggregated performance, right?
So
can you trust the aggregated PPV when applied to
a very rare cancer? Can you prove that point?
I would just add, I think government has a role to play here, as a
facilitator. I'm not exactly sure to describe what that
role is.
But for government to be on the sideline, leaving it just
to industry to pioneer this, it's probably not a good strategy.
We worked on the MCIT bill
with the American Cancer Society.
Enjoyed that work tremendously. And I think there's an opportunity
to come back to government with some thoughts about how we can
facilitate the data collection and analysis, and there are all kinds of
ways we can do it. But I think it's time for government, particularly with
this new science, to make sure that it gets out to the American
public as quickly as possible, that it can play a really interesting role
here.
All right. Thank you. I think we're going to let you have the last word there.
Appreciate everybody's attention.
Please check out bloodpact.org if you want to know more about this consortia
group.